they're all passing welcome to Stanford
and thanks very much I've been here
before
um I've lectured a couple of times at
the Hoover Institute where I think they
were acting nervous about my own brand
of conservatism um but I survived in one
piece survived long enough to go and do
one of do two of the lakeside talks at
Bohemia Grove so I've been through every
sort of anthropological excitement
imaginable in north California well we
appreciate you hopping across the pond
to join us again today and whilst we're
spoiled with many a guest throughout the
year few have been involved in so many
historical moments as your good self nor
worked with so many leaders ranging from
Thatcher through to to the Pope and so
we've got quite quite a lot to cover but
I'll try and take a whistle-stop stall
through it all and perhaps given that
the audience is Stanford students we can
start with your role as the Chancellor
of Oxford and how you given that it's
such a historical old educational
institute how you are ensuring to keep
it relevant and that it continues to
attract top global talent first of all a
word about the about the role
Oxford is a is a the oldest a university
and Britain they're not the oldest in
Europe or indeed in Europe and Africa
I suppose the oldest in Europe or Africa
is fairs and the oldest in Europe
probably Bologna or Paris we're pretty
old were getting on for 900 years and we
have a college which the professor was I
called new college and it's called new
ecology because it was fronted in what
the 15th century 13th century its edge
very it's very very new my old college
my old college was founded in the 12th
century and it celebrates its eight
hundred or eight hundred and fiftieth
anniversary about every two years it's
making money they're being they've been
a lot of Chancellor's over the years I
do point out that at Cambridge three of
their chancellors have been executed and
one has been canonized whereas at Oxford
three have been canonized anyone's been
executed so so we've done we've done
rather better the these days the the
Chancellor is elected by all graduates
um there of any I'm only the fourth
since 1935 Lord Halifax who was
ambassador in the States and foreign
secretary in 35 Harold Macmillan who was
Prime Minister in 1960 Roy Jenkins who
was imprisoned of the European
Commission and probably the greatest
reforming interior Home Secretary in our
politics since the war in 1983 and I was
elected in 2003 and the job is elected
for life and I used to say like the Pope
but I can't say that anymore so like the
Dalai Lama I probably can't say that
over any Chinese representatives present
but um and the job is m1 surrounded by
mystery Roy Jenkins my predecessor used
to say it was one in which M impotence
was ass waged by magnificence
his predecessor Harold Macmillan who was
a sort of Edwardian intellectual used to
offer a more metaphysical explanation he
used to say well as you know the
vice-chancellor actually runs the
university but if you didn't have a
chancellor you couldn't have a
vice-chancellor so I do I'm like a sort
of ceremonial monarch I'm a I'm a
constitutional monarch lots of
ceremonial stuff lots of fundraising I
chair selections of new vice chancellors
and generally try to make a pain of
myself with governments if they're not
supportive enough of the university the
most important thing
for us to do at the at Oxford is to
ensure that we remain M a terrific
teaching institution George Kennan who I
think is one of the great princes of
American Republic George Kennan said
teaching at Oxford he thought was
incomparable and even though it's
expensive we have to try to keep it that
way with our tutorial system and we have
to make sure that we are still pushing
the boundaries of knowledge as far
forward as possible our Medical Sciences
Division and dare I say this in Stanford
has come top of the global league tables
for five years running now our math and
engineering have got better and better
one of our senior mathematicians won the
Abel prize M this year and humanities at
Oxford terrific I would like them to be
even better and I'm particularly
concerned at the moment that while we
can still raise quite easily with a bit
of effort M funding for scholarships for
graduate studies in sciences and
medicine it's much more difficult to do
so in the humanities and that is because
partly I think because of the
disgraceful way in which M universities
tend to be judged in almost a
utilitarian fashion these days rather
than for more general considerations and
to find myself as Chancellor
occasionally having to M make speeches
justifying teaching the humanities is a
bit annoying but as I always say we
teach the humanities because we're human
so my job is to try to ensure that m and
people continue to deliver the quality
of teaching we require and the quality
of research we've just appointed M a new
vice-chancellor whose irish-american
Trinity College Dublin UCLA there
perfect Harvard she was one of drew
faust
protegees and ranley she was executive
Dean of the School of Advanced Studies
there then Rance and Andrews in the UK
where she and other things had to take
on the Royal and Ancient Golf Club and
what I will not say because I think it
slightly offensive and so I went to make
the point that she's the first woman
who's ever been vice-chancellor of
Oxford and but she is and she's
absolutely terrific and a great expert
on international security and has
written I've spent quite a lot of my
life in politics dealing with terrorism
and I think she's written the best
academic studies of how to deal with
terrorism that I've read by anyone so on
the topic of progressing ideas and as we
move to what many are calling me new
with new innovation of economy and a
knowledge-based economy Silicon Valley
is especially well-placed to do so but I
think London's too far behind
considering we've now got our own little
bubble of San Francisco it's essentially
Silicon Valley New York and Washington
in one and but as as we strive to to
adopt new new technology and innovation
what hurdles do you think remains on for
London to and the UK to progress and
become a little bit more like Silicon
Valley well I think this I think there's
a there's a there are two basic ones um
first of all if British politicians
aren't worried about the standard of
math in our secondary schools they
should be and secondly and I think that
we don't have as natural and innovative
culture as exists in the United States I
was interested yesterday one of the
young he was then a young undergraduate
who helped to organize my campaign for
mayor for governor of
and not not even that last job I had for
Chancellor of the University um he was
at the reception we had last night in
Palo Alto and I said Oh what are you
doing here and he said I'm I'm now the
economic I know I had the Economics
Department at Google um and you know
terrific that he's here but I wish he
was doing something em to promote
innovative culture in the EM in the UK
so I think we lack the same innovative
culture and we haven't made some of the
investments which would have helped to
make us even more competitive for
example there is an obvious requirement
for a for a corridor technology and
transport corridor between Oxford and
Cambridge which together are formidable
and with a growing and successful record
of spin-off and with a lot of shared
interests and and I think that the
government's in the United Kingdom have
been pathetic over the years in in
investment I don't think infrastructure
investment has been a great story in the
United States since probably President
Eisenhower but that's a that's perhaps
another matter but I think
infrastructure investment improving the
level of basic math in schools and
trying to do more to promote innovation
I I don't think myself that that has as
much to do with the tax system as some
right-wing politicians think but there
are other things you can do to promote
to promote that culture I suspect I'll
skip over the topic of taxes and and on
the it's interesting around how this
innovation has been progressive in many
ways and yet the gap between the rich
and the poor seem to be increasing over
time how do you think we can reconcile
this progression in a more sustainable
manner Bo and bring everyone else at all
I think that's it's that's very
interesting and I guess profoundly
relevant to what's happening in your own
domestic politics on which Habib M
blessedly almost silent but also on ours
as well Kerra there's a very good book
which I read recently I think it's
called concrete economics or concrete
reality which makes the point that M
it's a complete fiction that wealth and
prosperity of always been created in the
United States by the private sector that
the government has always been a drag
not true
you start with Alexander Hamilton Teddy
Roosevelt and FDR you even look at the
period of the long Ike boom and see a
combination of public investment M & M
private endeavor so the city on a hill
was built by government as well as by
the private sector M and he the long Ike
boom which probably lasted into the
sixties mmm saw the Gini coefficient and
you all know what that is M falling to
the lowest level in American economic
history so that from 1940 I think about
1946-47 the Gini coefficient was moving
in the right direction and since 1968
it's been going in the other direction
and I sometimes wonder how American
politicians get away with the fact that
there is such an astonishing multiple of
CEOs pay to Meanor mean or average
earnings and there is I think a lot of
evidence that this is because people
don't actually know what the figures are
they can't believe the figures if
they're told there when asked they think
there's a multiple of 30
and they don't know there's a multiple
ten times or more than ten times that
size so I think the levels of social
inequity M in the United States and
where we've been moving in that
direction in the United Kingdom are
becoming politically hazardous and if I
had to try to explain one of the reason
why the for the rage which helps to
sustain mr. Trump's ambitions I would
guess that social equity is a is a very
big reason and I also am think that it
that there is a relationship between
social equity and the sense people have
that M globalization is wrecking their
prospects and delivering prosperity
everybody everywhere else except America
it's not of course true and but
nevertheless there is that perception
and we have that in the United Kingdom
as well the sense people have that they
want to get the world and get off we
stop the world and get off em that they
want control over their own lives M in a
way in a mythical way which has never
really existed and certainly hasn't
existed during fast periods of
globalization either in the 19th century
or in the last few years in the United
Kingdom in the last few weeks we've seen
the near demise of our steel industry
why first of all because of the dumping
of cheap steel by China which is
producing about half the total amount of
steel in the world and which saw an
increase in its steel production of 300
percent between 2008 and last year the
British steel industry has in terms of
its competitiveness has been has been
completely screwed because of that so
who's suffering not just the workers but
an Indian company which owns the British
steel industry
so when people talk about about
controlling their lives so that they can
protect their jobs and their children
their family's living standards that's
not the world we live in anymore even if
it has been for the last few years and I
would wish that people were making the
case for for free trade fair trade but
free trade we're making the case the
positive case for globalization and more
effectively and more toughly than they
are it seems to me that the real one of
the most important things really the
most important thing we should be doing
in response to the competitiveness of
globalization is investing more in our
public education and in the improvement
of our public education system in my own
country in particular I'm investing in
further education we've always been
really bad
at any vocational education particularly
in comparison with with Germany so I
think social equity is an important part
of this but only only part of a broader
nexus of issues and which touch
globalization as well good old good old
eysan her well then it's interesting
like in in europe they often refer to
nowadays is the Jonker curse around
politicians know what to do they just
don't know how to do it and get
reelected so now that you're across
Spencer and I believe you've referred
yourself as a liberal internationalists
these days as opposed to just a
Conservative MP how do you think about
commentary that politics is increasingly
orchestrated politicians are caught up
in opinion polls and going to focus
groups to guide them as to what to do
next and balancing the need to be
responsive to the electorate but not
just reactionary and be able to deliver
a manifesto to address some of the
issues
you just raise I don't see any point in
going into politics unless you've got
strong views about things and one of the
things I find infinitely depressing is
politicians who have to ask a focus
group what they should be concerned
about and then ask another caucus group
how they should explain their concerns
about whatever the first focus group has
told them should be bothering them and
one of the reasons why I've found I'm
not making a political pitch I suppose I
earn money and one of the reasons why
I've found President Obama
such an attractive human being is he
does seem to me when he's talking about
events which really mattered to him like
his own identity and the relationship
between his identity and the culture and
political culture in which he has to
operate you get the sense that that this
is not something he's had to ask
somebody how to express I mean I thought
the two speeches he gave the one speech
he gave in his pastors Church before the
2008 election about race in politics and
the speech he gave a few months ago
after the slaughter of some African
American worshipers in a church in the
south of those those speeches were
astonishingly powerful because that was
him because that wasn't some other guy
with the yellow legal pad writing the
words down and it was authentically him
so if you didn't have strong views about
what society should be like I mean
become a chartered accountant make some
money I mean but or a venture capitalist
really still absolutely still have very
strong views but I didn't I didn't see
the point in in going into politics
unless you really feel passionately
about about one or two issues what most
worries me
well what would no waste most worry me
if I was a American citizen I think is
the extraordinary power of big money in
politics I mean
shouldn't mention names but you know the
sort of people I'm talking about and
quite quite how the Supreme Court can
define spending huge amounts of untaxed
loot on supporting partisan opinions
partly because they suit your own
business interests how they can define
that as covered by the EM freedom of
speech amendment I simply don't
comprehend I was very impressed by
Justice Scalia's intellect but that
seems to me and what to use one of his
phrases what he would have called pure
applesauce and and the tsundere there is
a Supreme Court which reverses that
decision I think the better for American
for American democracy those of you who
are historians of America which I'm not
and may regard what I'm about to say is
too simplistic but it always seemed to
me that the that the majesty of the
American political system was balancing
a constitution which established a
republic not necessarily a democracy
with a political system which is
democratic and in order to make to
balance the two in order to make the
checks and balances of the first
something other than vetoes on action
you do need to have am the ability to
compromise to make consensus is and so
on which seems to me to be something
with the Smithsonian these days when I
first got involved in politics it was in
a mayoral campaign in New York in the
1960s when the Republican Party in New
York was led by senator Javits senator
Keating Nelson Rockefeller and John
Lindsay can you imagine what the Tea
Party would make of of that these days
so if we think about the political
actions which you're best known for it's
the last colonial governor closing the
final chapter
the good old British Empire and so in
okay so it when when we look back in
terms of the sino-british joint
declaration it seems that you had
remarkable clarity as to how you'd make
progress towards a ninety seven deadline
and you you stopped with and had courage
of your convictions despite great
outrage from Beijing at the time I think
they cursed you 2,000 years of hardship
his sentence was remitted subsequently
but I'll be reinstated I think given
what I've been saying about students in
in Hong Kong but that's not a matter and
and even you know the some of the former
Brits you're out there weren't
supportive and the stock exchange
collapsed and what gave you that courage
to go on despite the naysayers and and
then follow through in the actions I
I've always felt most comfortable in
politics when and then this forgive this
me if this sounds a bit sanctimonious
when I've thought that what I was doing
was not only the right thing to do but
the but right um and it seemed to me
that we had made promises to people in
Hong Kong which we were creeping away
from about a month or six weeks before I
left Hong Kong
I was visiting as as governor a hospital
for the mentally ill and it was in a
series of sort of low bungalows each of
them fenced in with a with a Santi a
with a passage through the middle and
I'm walking along and a very very
well-dressed Chinese chap in a
three-piece suit gray suit and wearing I
think I remember a Homburg starts
calling to me from behind one of these
fenced enclosures governor patten gonna
patent
and to the horror of my staff I walked
across to talk to him and he was
incredibly polite - what - his lethal
when people are polite and he said
governor pattern can you can you explain
this to me he said you you very often
you and other British colleagues talk
about Britain being the oldest democracy
in the world I nervously agreed so he
said well could you explain this to me
why is it that you're handing over em
the last British colony to the last
great communist tyranny in the world
without ever consulting the people about
it so here was the sameness man in Hong
Kong who was in a hospital for the
mentally ill now there was actually no
alternative but but the transfer of
sovereignty in Hong Kong Hong Kong or
most of Hong Kong had been only taken on
a lease and the terms in which both the
lease had been negotiated and the grant
of the rest of the Hong Kong had been
there made were clearly matters of 19th
century history which nobody and would
seek to justify in the 20th or 20th 21st
century it was a period when Western
powers not least the United Kingdom were
trying to globalize China by opening it
opening it to the opium trade I mean
this is not something that even Queen
Victoria found particularly is
particularly attractive and so we had no
alternative but to M hand Hong Kong back
to China and but but we'd undertaken
with the Chinese agreement that Hong
Kong would be guaranteed that its way of
life to process em freedom of speech
freedom of worship rule of law and so on
would carry on for 50 years off
1997 em and to be kind to China it may
be that there were conceptual
difficulties let me give you an example
I didn't I I got excessively praised for
rather limited things I did on democracy
because I was operating within very
strict agreed guidelines mmm
but I was trying to ensure that
elections were at least free and fair
and one of my critics who is a spokesman
for the Beijing ERG a night perfectly
nice Jam said to me you don't seem to
understand our position we're not at all
against free and fair elections we just
want to know the result in advance and I
realized at that point that we were not
going to have an easy way of connecting
of reaching of reaching agreement and I
sometimes actually think that it's that
it is quite difficult for people with my
sort of background small-l liberal
pluralist and so on to really understand
and that Chinese Communist mindset I
don't necessarily is a Chinese mindset
because you can think of lots of Chinese
communities which are profoundly liberal
and pluralist and what what's I think
been a worry about what's happened
subsequently is that those in Hong Kong
who feel primarily Chinese also want
Beijing to understand that they feel
that their Hong Kong Chinese
that they have a sense of citizenship
which may not be as powerful as their
sense of chineseness but in terms of the
complexity of the ayah of complexity of
their identity it's really important and
to some extent trampling that underfoot
as the their crudest Beijing has done
recently and I think Preston's President
Xi's arrival I think that's been really
counterproductive I mean I went I went
with my wife to an Oxford alumni
gathering in Hong Kong this time last
year no just this time two years ago and
I was coming out of receptions and
meetings and there would be a hundred or
200 students a lot of them who had
hardly been born when I left Hong Kong
singing Rule Britannia and God Save the
Queen and I mean it was terrific for my
reputation in all Oxford I can tell you
but but you could understand how
provocative it would have been to the M
governing authorities in China and
that's their fault it's really
unnecessary and silly that they've
provoked that sort of reaction but I
have huge respect for thee for the
students who were demonstrating 18
months ago for democracy with the most
extraordinary politeness and good
manners imaginable
so it's essentially that you've been
involved in conflict resolution across
continents
also most notably in the Balkans as well
as Northern Ireland and as development
officer with the Ethiopian Sudan it
seems that you're very good at bringing
all parties to the table and giving an
incentive most notably with the Balkans
encouraging regime change by suggesting
membership of the EU how do you think
through this kind of carrot and stick
approach to resolution and are there any
common takeaways you can share with us
as to progressing discussions in the
heat of the moment and moving things
forward
I've become obsessed over the years with
identity politics and how lethal lethal
identity politics can be I've worked in
Northern Ireland I've worked in the
Balkans I've worked in the Middle East I
worked in Asia em and the extent to
which em when people identify themselves
with a very simple pure-blooded
set of loyalties when that turns into a
facility to imagine that they're being
victimized and when they're rather crude
and simple sentiments are whipped up by
demagogues it nearly always leads to
disaster the most difficult job I did
was after the Good Friday Agreement
which to Tony Blair's credit and mo
Mowlam credit they managed to negotiate
and the one thing that nobody could
agree about was policing the police
force in Northern Ireland at the time
was regarded as an arm of a Protestant
state Northern Ireland was probably 53%
52% Protestant and 47 48 % Catholics the
police force was 93 percent Protestant
and 7 percent Catholic and that was
plainly not something that could survive
in a new Northern Ireland resolving that
issue involve doing a lot of things
which were politically very difficult
but it seemed to me that that these were
corners you couldn't cut you actually
have to you actually had to face up to
the difficulties of changing names of
changing symbols um and we did that and
at the time they were roars of
disapproval from the Ulster Unionist but
it's lasted and one result is that today
the police service in Northern Ireland
is
pretty well 3035 percent Catholic and
the rest Protestant I mean it's been a
real transformation em providing so
first of all I think you have to stand
up to the rougher read rougher side of
identity politics secondly you have to
provide a political context in which
people can extract themselves from the
corners of rooms they've painted
themselves into or get off Hawks
something I used to get annoyed about
when negotiating with Chinese
interlocutors but they were always
saying to me and but you've got to
understand we've got face you got to
learn to save you know the web we need
to have our safest night station
I've got bloody phase two if that's what
you got to understand other people have
have face which needs to be taken
account of when I was a European
Commissioner mr. Aznar and the then
prime minister of M Spain pretty tough
fellow am asked to see me because he'd
heard that I'd worked in Northern
Ireland and he was reading across to the
situation in the Basque countries and
the Terrorism of etta em and he wanted
to know what I thought should be done
about policing in Spain in order to and
help her undermine it her and I started
I went in to my schpeel about the
political background in Northern Ireland
and what we'd done on issues like
housing and local government and
education and job creation and I could
see him glazing over because I didn't
have a simple hard
sock it to him
response so there's always there's
always a context which you've got to try
to create but ultimately you actually
have to stand up to the worst sort of
identity politics there's a fantastic
book well there's a very good book on
identity politics by Amartya Sen there's
another very good one by a French
novelist called Armin Maloof who's won
the gong core and several other prizes I
think his main novel was called the rock
of Tallis
um I mean Maloof is actually was
actually born in Lebanon Arab Christian
writes in French our lives in France and
he's written a brilliant book about and
the complexities of identity you think
about your identities I've thought about
mine I'm Irish lower to middle
middle-class Catholic Tory what my Irish
forebears would have thought about being
me being a colonial governor but they
were they were my great-grandfather was
was born in Ireland in 1829 left Ireland
during them during the famine so we all
have these these M complicated em
identities ourselves and Maalouf says at
the end of his extraordinary am CAF
acerbic attack on identity identity
politics says that normally when you're
a writer and you hope that in the future
your grandsons granddaughters will take
books off the shelf and think oh this is
wonderful book gosh did our grandfather
really write this he said his hope was
that when his grandson took I think it's
called this book is called the pursuit
of identity or the question of identity
and takes it off the shelf he'll look at
it and think my goodness did people have
to write books about this in those days
so it's a
tall order but I hope that some identity
politics is something we can start to
eliminate even while comprehending the
complexities of other people's identity
and the importance to other people
should be should have an identity which
is respected and is given the dignity it
deserves so on the topic of shaping
identity he later went on to be the the
chairman of a media review for the Pope
now considering that they announce their
election results through three smoke
signals are not quite so sure how one
goes about reviewing a the digital media
policy in coming up with Twitter and so
forth but can you talk a little bit
about how that came about and the effect
you think it's had and and the drive and
reach is achieved well the message the
invitation was of course brought by Dove
carry a carrier dove yes um I was quite
surprised to be asked to do it but but
jumped at it I'm a cradle Catholic and
I'm a huge admirer of this Pope and I
was I what would be regarded as a fairly
liberal Catholic I didn't think the
Archbishop of San Francisco would have a
much truck with some of my opinions um
so a great admirer M and
thought that it was a pity that a man
who was probably the best communicator
in the world M had a pretty to put it
mildly archaic way of communicating I
mean the budget in the Vatican um when
we started work was pretty well 92%
spent on a newspaper the observatory
Romano and on radio and we all know that
most people are getting their
information on television and social
media so actually even from that sort of
for point of view there was a lot to be
done we I had a very good team including
a brilliant social media expert who just
happens to be an ex-banker but now a
member of the Dominicans a great French
priest holy rexella beer had a very very
good group of others and from outside to
excellent
women a German and a Spanish and we put
together a series of proposals which the
Pope which is holiness accepted em and
established a team of Italians to
implement so I hope it some time there
was no there was no there was no there
was no footnote to that observation but
I hope it I hope it I hope it some it
goes well it's very important that it
should I mean to be fair to the to the
person who's leading this team and he's
been head of Vatican television for a
long time and the and the technical
competence of Vatican television is is
extraordinarily high but it does matter
and particularly matters that people are
getting and the sort of social media
messages which which they require when
when I am on today with the time of mass
I look it up as I would look up them um
trailer for films I mean it's some and I
think most people are like that and
that's not I'm surprised when they can't
get the information that they want he is
a remarkable man
um and we must all hope he survives I
had I used to have my meetings in the
Santa Marta which is the
Hostel that he lives in and one day we'd
had a meeting and we were having lunch
and it was his birthday this would have
been December 2014 I suppose and he is
sitting with with cleaning ladies and
the laboratory attendants and and the
cooks having his birthday lunch and I
said to the very nice Irish priest who
was looking after me but it was a
terrific terrific sight and he said yes
you haven't had the best of it though he
said he was as his popemobile was
crossing some Peter's Square he was
stopped by a group of Argentinean
pilgrims with a bowl of that em drink
herbal drink Ma Tei which some of you
may love not say I prefer a dry martini
anyway he he's handed he's handed the
mottai and takes a great swig out of it
and the Hizb is detectives his bodyguard
says honey father you must never do that
you can never take a drink from people
in the streets it could be poison so the
Pope had replied apparently what's the
matter he said they were pilgrims not
Cardinals
so we must hope we must hope he survives
so I think with that I'll turn to the
audience for for questions and I believe
we have a couple of microphones roaming
around Celine I don't know if we have a
question from Twitter to start question
whilst I have a question from Twitter so
a lot of us have worked with very
different managers but why was it like
working with the Pope and the Queen um
different sexes I must say just one
point on that which is not irrelevant
when I first went to one of the Pope's
private masses I said to the my
secretary Lam a priest how does this
differ from what would have been
wouldn't what he would have been like
under previous popes and he said easy
said there are women on the altar and
the Pope I'll tell you one similarity
and I don't want to be accused of lays
measures day either in its
ecclesiastical form or its corporal for
it's less spiritual form and they're
both quite simple and straightforward em
neither than remotely ground when you're
going when when I had conversations with
with Pope Francis and when it was
business and it would be one on one or
one with interpreted as my Italian isn't
as good as it should be and now other
people around in a simple rather a
dreary little waiting room in the Santa
Marta not not sort of lots of purple and
scarlet and sashes and Berettas and and
so on
similar similarly when you and when you
see the Queen she's perfectly normal and
and straightforward starts the day as
most of us do in Britain listening to
the BBC radio and today programme and
she is she is what you would have
expected of somebody born in the 1930s
yeah just or twenties twenties
em English em British upper class she's
got all the um she has she starts with
those opinions which have been modified
over the years by the number of Prime
Minister she'd seen come and go in the
number of them members of the public
she's met the extraordinary thing is
this for somebody of her age um how
enthusiastically she goes about her
public duties having had to do a bit of
that as AG as a colonial governor um it
can be pretty boring and she never gives
that she never gives that impression at
all so what they both exemplify is a
very old-fashioned virtue which I hope
exists I mean I've done some jobs in
business but I hope exists in business
or it should exist in everybody's life
and makes things easier they both have a
sense of duty and obligation and maybe
if only as citizens that's something
which we should feel so yeah they're
perfectly normal to deal with em and
quite funny it's great Queen has a very
good sense of humor so next question
I am NOT pattern thank you so much for
your tightening speech today my name is
neon I'm a second year MBA student um a
question regarding since you're Tori I
was wondering if you could comment a
little bit about how the recent release
of the Panama papers would have on the
Cameron government and also given that
you spoke very eloquently about social
inequity looking back at the previous
view government's the Prime Minister's
deputy Prime Minister's Nick Clegg David
Cameron Tony Blair they all belong to
the Oxbridge Lee and do you think that
kind of social stratification is going
to continue going forward second
question is if you were able to talk
presidency right now I think we just
start with it though this that was
already - just there so if we start
start with those two pretty meaty
questions I mean let me let me deal with
the second one first and it's true that
there are a huge number of British Prime
Minister's and ministers and member of
part numbers of parliament and judges
and senior executives and editors of
newspapers from of left right and centre
a huge number of people who AM run
things in the United Kingdom who went to
Oxford and Cambridge and why is that and
the reason is that M Oxford and
Cambridge along with M Imperial and UCL
and King's College London are the best
universities and the toughest ones to
get into and it shouldn't be a surprise
that the people who go look it's true
very largely in the United States it
shouldn't be a surprise that the people
who are smart enough to go to the
toughest universities and go on to and
get to the top in other careers I think
we haven't
an establishment which is overwhelmingly
meritocratic and it's overwhelmingly
based on competence rather than
connections though connections can come
into it but I'm nowadays described by
the M by the popular press as a Tory
grandi my mother who was not unknown to
be a bit of a and unfair to say social
climber but she liked to think that she
was cut off for slightly M classier blog
and my mother would have been delighted
to hear me called a Tory Grandy
Here I am my dad was a professional
drummer in a jazz band and we lived in a
semi-detached house in a in a part of
London suburbs which was on the margins
between lower and middle-class um I went
on a scholarship to secondary schools I
went on the scholarship when I was 16
from my secondary school to Oxford I'm a
scholarship boy and I found my I found
myself and in my life doing jobs
surrounded by other scholarship boys now
it is true that M David Cameron M is an
old atonium M but his and his
predecessor was but his predecessor was
a Scottish grammar school boy his
predecessor was at a rather grand school
in Scotland his predecessor John major
left school at 16 M and his father so
garden gnomes and his first job
interview was to become a bus conductor
and he was turned down his predecessor
was Margaret Thatcher whose father was
his father ran a grocery in was a
scholarship girl her predecessor
I could go on ask instead of the
Conservative Party was the son of a
small building version my wife used to
stay with some friends in the town where
he worked and whenever the laboratories
were blocked they'd send for Ted Heath's
father so so I think we're a much more
socially mobile society and it's not
surprising that people from the from
what are the most difficult universities
to get into and finish up doing some of
the toughest jobs but what is incredibly
important for any meritocracy is to
ensure that it recognizes that there are
even broader ladders behind it in order
to let people climb up them what's
incredibly important for people like me
m and others is to recognize the role of
the state in helping us up the ladders
and to recognize that the state is still
required to help people from poorer and
more disadvantaged backgrounds and to
get onto the matter and to rise to rise
up it so I think meritocracies have to
be benign and sensitive to the interests
of those who are coming after them if
they're going to justify themselves on
the Panama papers the Prime Minister M I
mean it this has been what all happens
since I've been away but as I understand
it
his father had established a trust M for
his it from which his family and
benefited when he died and as well as
I'll be able benefited I don't think
anybody has suggested it was a way of
evading tax or covering up the billions
that you'd earned as was the case with
mr. Putin for example am and I think I'm
right in saying it's the sort of trust
which if you're an American citizen you
don't have to go to Panama
to set up because there at least two
American states where you can do it
anyway I read em Fareed Zakaria this
week on why there were no American names
in the Panama papers and his argument
was well you didn't have to do that if
you were an American so um I don't think
the I don't think I think undoubtedly
Cameron suffers from a bit will suffer
from a bit for people being reminded
that he was a rich tough and I'm not
quite sure how long that lasts and I
regard M wealth envy as one of the less
pleasant aspects of living in a
democracy
so no platon I am I have the the
privilege of asking the last question
and you wrote a book what next for the
21st century
and that's kind of a question that many
of us especially second-year students
here asking ourselves so what are the
big problems that you see that serve I
should put our binds to to start solving
for or what pearls of wisdom would you
like to share with us to close I sent a
copy of my book what next to the then
Chancellor of Cambridge University who
was the Duke of Edinburgh the Queen's
husband and he was then well into his
80s he's now well into his 90s and he
sent me back a handwritten reply saying
hmm what next question mark when you're
my age does anyone arms
yeah he's probably what what what next I
tell you what what I find surprising and
I think it's going to be the sort of key
a sort of nodal issue in the next few
years um most of us understand most of
us recognize intellectually that very
few of the problems that weigh on our
societies very few very few of the
problems that that confront our
societies can be dealt with by
individual countries em and yet at the
same time the enthusiasm for
International Cooperation to tackle
those problems has waned significantly
so whether you're talking about epidemic
disease or international economic issues
trade or environmental issues or
trafficking human beings or trafficking
em guns and none of those issues can be
tackled unless there is m cooperation
and while that is true the support for M
shared sovereignty for shared
policymaking has declined significantly
I think it's a real problem I think here
in the United States you have a
difficulty that the Republicans believe
in free trade but not in the
institutions which are necessary in
order to sustain it and the Democrats
believe in the institution's but not in
the free trade I think that's a there
are similar problems in in other
countries so I think reigniting a belief
in in international cooperation and
international institutions to give
credibility and legitimacy to that and
cooperation
I think that is hugely important
um and should be invested with a degree
of hope which doesn't at present exist I
think the one of the things that it
universities
great universities like this one should
do exist to do is to provide hope at the
end of them one of the most remarkable
books about international relations I've
read Henry Kissinger's book on diplomacy
which was written in the mid-1990s
whatever people think about Henry
Kissinger's record as a in government he
was he's an extraordinary fine historian
and he's written diplomacy is a book
about the post-war settlement the great
contribution of the United States to the
world after 1945 with some help from
Europe the way that had brought peace
and certainly in Europe for a longer
period than anything since the Congress
of Vienna and he writes at the end about
how that's shaking too shaken to pieces
the point I've just made and he quotes
an old Spanish saw an old Spanish
proverb traveler where is the road don't
ask where the road is roads are made by
walking and I think it's the role of
universities to do some of the walking
and to show us where the roads are um
and I can think of no better or more
important a task for universities offer
university teachers offer university
students and the last thing you should
do it at a university is think that it's
somewhere where you can go to be safe or
protected
the world I can make one last
controversial point I think that I think
it's an optimal an oxymoron to talk
about universities and safe spaces in
the same breath and I think University
it's all about challenge and finding
those roads em which will get us from
one predicament to another because
that's what being a lives all about
that's a delightful note on which to end
we'll all go out and walk and chart our
own paths
so please join me a welcoming and
thanking